China
well listen frankly China they're
killing us they're killing us to China
to killing us to China the killing us
here at the border you get here we
caught and tried get like a plastic
knife and fork tout at the Trump Tower
food court it's made in China you can't
use it you can't cut Freight truthfully
I would never use those forks I would
never use those knives if I were the one
in charge of making forks knives I would
say this is come on this is ridiculous
you got to start making better stuff
here and frankly the people on the other
end who were making the forks and knives
they would take my calls but with China
okay with China they don't care they
don't have any ethics they don't care
what they're doing here they're killing
us at the border that killing us at the
China and if I work what they rent from
me the Chinese they love me they'll
spend millions of dollars for the Trump
Tower those millions of dollars in a
truthfully the Chinese they have an
apartment they have a right here the
biggest Chinese Bank of the world thing
they bank with Trump I order so much moo
shu pork they call me the pork machine
but strike that will let it I don't want
pork in government but I want book in my
body because I like book frankly if I
were the one in charge of pork farming
over in China I would make a phone call
I'd make a deal and you could bet that
the pork farmer in China frankly would
take my calls
they'd take my calls look here here we
answer more of your questions about the
Bible click here to watch the Bible part
2 because I know a lot about the Bible I
read the Bible a lot